Also,
when I'm going to be in a wrestling attitude,
in wrestling attitude,
I'm in a bass war.
My eyes are important.
If I look at my opponent's feet,
I can't be strong.
My head is not straight,
my back will round up.
I have no power in my back,
so to keep 1 solid guard,
my head must be straight.
To have a straight back,
1 impact power.
Even when I go down,
I put the knee down and straighten up,
I stay with my back straight forever
have the power to right me.
If I basically have my eyes down,
look down there,
I'll come and attack.
My attack,
it is down.
How do you want to right the opponent?
He has already pressed,
already defended,
it's too hard,
it's not obvious,
ok?
So right back,
straight head.
If I go down,
I'm high,
I'm straight.
I always look at the opponent,
at least I can see what he does.
If I'm tired and I'm here,
I can't see anything.
Now I'm tired,
ok,
he's going through this,
he'll take 1 wrist,
I'll look at him,
okay.
So when I tell you your moves,
it is very important.
Straight head,
I always look at 1 opponent,
I move,
I have my opponent,
I imagine him in front of me,
I memorize him,
it's there,
right? Boom hop,
I can dodge,
I attack, okay?